it looks like a dried little
turd what about the
taste I can't do
[Music]
that hi this is Julia Fox and this is
snack Wars for lad Bible today we are
going to be doing UK versus
USA oh pizza and this
what is this looks like airplane food so
this is cottage pie cottage pie like
cottage cheese like a kind of shepherd's
pie like the is shepherd's pie guys I'm
from New York we don't eat this we eat
pasta and pizza and bagels I mean it
smells kind of
good I like it look good what is this um
layer of white thing on top is that
potato mashed potato that's not mashed
Mas potato that is not mashed potato
pizza oh wow this is a very serious
pizza with some very crusty pepperonis
yummy so what is better Italian pizza or
American Italian pizza I am such a bad
Italian cuz I've never had a pizza I
didn't like I just think you can't go
wrong it's tomato cheese bread it's
usually always amazing but I think that
for the first time I'm going to have a
pizza I don't like cuz it looks like a
Colony or a growth of some sort
underneath this cheese is this a faka it
looks like a faka with cheese on it I
think this is like an American Pizza of
this is not American what are you
talking
[Music]
about oh I hate that I actually have for
the first time in my life have tried a
pizza I don't like yeah that's gross
I'll go back to my weird shepherd's pie
yeah I you K wins but that's because you
guys got a bad pizza so put that in the
notes ah oh peanut butter and jelly wait
what's
this have you heard about this no not
this Mite is this
Mite okay you British this is not a good
PB&J ratio okay you shouldn't be able to
see the PB it has to be more
J so pretty good would you usually go
for this for your breakfast oh one yeah
absolutely I eat this almost every day
and it's like I'm a mom so it's easy to
make and it's
delish
oh it smells like soy sauce yeah it's
supposed to it's East okay and I have to
eat this I can't just like pretend you
know they say you are the love it or
hates
it there's no way people eat
this like how many people are we talking
here 50 to
70% okay I'm going to go back
to cleanse my
palette okay that was
disgusting I'm sorry I don't mean to be
rude but that was really really
awful clear
winner I think USA T takes the the win
for this this is this was this is should
be illegal are all of them going to be
like this cuz I'll leave right
now ah
okay okay all right I like know what
these taste like already so I'm going to
try these first um
twiglets that's a funny
name
yikes can you show us how twiglet look
looks
like it looks like a dried little
turd it looks like a turd On a Winter's
day what about the
tast I can't do that I'm sorry bitter no
salt tastes like dirt they like actually
taste like a twig that was really bad
sorry I need a palette cleanse with
something I know I'm so bad at opening
bags I'm embarrassed what's your
favorite Cheetos flavor you know I'm
actually more of a classic Cheetos girl
the flaming hot is like a little too hot
for me but um I definitely will like it
more than
this yeah oh my God so much better look
at the
difference it's like take notes twiglets
come on you're almost
there do people really eat twiglets you
guys people love twiglets I'll tell you
more you Brits you guys have been
through some and it shows the famines
and all the things it it I see the signs
the residual trauma is Alive and Well
tra F yeah it's trauma food
guys ah ice cream and
a fruit
pel pastels yeah so this is basically a
popsicle and we're a b f okay I am I am
a big I eat like about I eat one of
these a day
[Music]
actually good what flavor is this one
cookie dough okay now I'm interested in
this cuz I'm a very big popsicle
connoisseur so what is the what is a
good popsicle
I I really really love lemon popsicles I
eat like almost a box a day
actually I don't know if it's cuz I just
had this so but this one is kind of a
multi flavor she me
too the lemon one is at the bottom you
want oh it does get better on
here I I don't know I think that I think
the ice cream might be better sorry
UK o what do we have here I feel like
this could give someone what's that like
the trick trophobia or when when the
little the porous things so it's a
crumpet a crumpet oh
wow I've heard of crumpets like tea and
crumpets and I I didn't know that this
was The Crumpet is this a carrot cake a
carrot loaf for that's one of your
favorites as well I don't think so honey
okay I've never seen this a day in my
life oh banana bread oh yes okay mine
looks a little different it's like
smothered in chocolate
but M so good so so good I know this
like are you guys serious with this what
is
this do people buy this in the store
yeah you need yeah you need to really
toast it cuz otherwise it's is this
toasted it doesn't feel toast feels
honestly it looks and it feels like a
sponge like that you would clean like
the toilet with
[Music]
guys
doesn't taste like
anything no taste
whatsoever you put Jam On It are the
holes to fill with Jam yeah you can put
jam
on don't even try I mean there's no no
comparison here like it's this is much
better this is disgusting okay and
obviously USA
[Music]
[Applause]
one oh no that was rotten egg oh no no
no no no no no no no no oh no it's liver
and onions
oh